every once in a while there is a story
that touches us just like Stephen
Collins did anyway this is Japan World
Cup it's a movie look I have it right
here it's it's two movie by horses
I couldn't finally any English subtitles
but this is also probably copyrighted
appears can't answer but sometimes you
got a little life and I kept going over
to do it on the edge
okay badge on you a stilt I cannot I'm
crying tears so the point of this game
if I understand it correctly it's like
you bet
Joshua knows hump you bench who's gonna
win the race
she's supposed to shuold am i right so
here are the contestant I'm guiding have
you got [ __ ] Japan we go [ __ ]
France is she wearing a Stephen yeah we
got Japan again how about it
the weird side of Japan never open I
thank you about what a [ __ ] player
hell yeah America is a tandem a tandem
horse that's racist
oh yes Japan Seeley pizzicato
okay it's a [ __ ] ball shoe up a
little bunnies oh yeah that's like again
yes the see Brett why don't you
understand Houthis I hear they taste
delicious the United Kingdom gets a
[ __ ] giraffe how's the cousin of eat
food in Seoul say status crisis from the
80s or some [ __ ] like I don't have to
Japan again oh my god what the that's
not a real horse ha that's all Joe I'm
gonna have to go I don't know who are
you betting on let me know in the
comments right now didn't see how you
came upon them I haven't decided yet I
have no idea what's going on okay okay
it's a first start I'm gonna have to go
with Elvis horse that's number three
that's number three
stylish Mexico number three yourself
Nikki come on number three Chitti bully
Malcolm come on Tilson Bunch Oh Bob you
oh geez I could even pop faster oh he's
good he's really good we got a chance
here Luigi [ __ ] America go away
I'm surprised a fake horse is not doing
better come on number three no [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] it on hello darkness my old friend
oh I'm sweating this is intense synth or
even gives me blue
oh he's catching up he's really on there
sassy shoe corn a simple applauded
[ __ ] giraffe he's catching up to
friends in the first bucket ah it must
be those tights
come on Japan number three oyster he's
picking up speed he's picking up speed
oh god damn it come on come on I got
[ __ ] fifty bucks on this [ __ ] no no
no no what the [ __ ] is that oh my god oh
I can't believe it all right that was
race one don't worry number three you're
still in the game all right
what's the score I don't [ __ ]
understand stop come on Elvis [ __ ]
that's kind of like choice silver again
yes number second come on what are they
saying I don't know they're still in the
race I'm thirsty I'd be [ __ ] awesome
if eight wins don't fault nevermind what
is Kenya doing Kenya is charging the
same right with Humphrey
but the [ __ ] is Japan doing fists in the
air grunts you [ __ ] [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] are you doing with this [ __ ]
understand
come in come on oh yes the helicoptering
oh man it's [ __ ] brilliant you know
what they deserved that one they really
do deserve that one because I ah
well played Kenya hooking them upon the
hip pocket let me stopping at all I do
him alright
race number three oh my lord this is
intense
keeping this daddy will keep it steady
come on okay it's the same [ __ ] every
time we're number two then friends [ __ ]
heads and they're gonna fall in fine
hatch about how do you pay for three
children
look up there it is
shucker come on Elvis you gotta win at
least one [ __ ] what is Kenya doing now
come on we're doing really well come on
Elvis yeah yeah
come on oh we're out of runs thank grant
what the [ __ ] are you no not that move
again we can't their movies and be in a
ball
oh [ __ ] this is a tight one for theirs
how do you mean stretch em paste you
stretched brilliant friends is in the
[ __ ] air look at that
[ __ ] Sonya oh god she's doing the
[ __ ] slaps again goddammit friends
you [ __ ] come on Elvis movement eater
someone's got hot something's gotta
happen Elvis what are you doing no was
that her pants
Noel me Oh what the [ __ ] they're going
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] Japan thumbnail you
know how thumbnail right there that is
just great Thank You friends
Thank You friends for that French how do
you appreciate it friends is it all
about being sexy assert some [ __ ]
nothing cause pain what are you oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Oh bunny okay I think he murdered
everyone
well played Spain fine fine but any
whooping I didn't see that one coming I
don't think the ball did either I don't
think come on Bakura crushed it up come
on eight
here's the curve you can do it we
practice getting really [ __ ] tired of
your shitty oh yeah it's definitely the
year of the giraffe come on giraffe
our God is using the dance move oh it's
Elvis what the [ __ ] is always doing what
is it what [ __ ] is that it's a
motorcycle he turned his horse in a
motorcycle genius come on a kocourek a
psycho be hot bang Haribo come on hope
takaka going occupy der Sar come on
don't [ __ ] miss the car that means
drivers gonna win this one guy I'm so
sick of [ __ ] Kenya I'm back he's
really tryharding all this [ __ ] that's
not gonna work [ __ ] you can yep I got
friends it is genetic everyone is doing
their thing
Oh giraffe oh oh [ __ ] he's head back
oh [ __ ] is getting an epic momentum come
on giraffe you got this [ __ ] oh I'm not
sure about our deep it I'm not sure
about that one
oh what the
EEMA well flayger wait well played UK
well played
so that means eight has to win this one
because it is the only one that's at one
point you put it you pick it doesn't win
one I'm gonna kill my side tonight if
not there is no more reason to live if
it doesn't win Vashti come on eight
you're not Jeff I'm glad you [ __ ]
idiot
Oh silence
Kenya it's starting to dance okay it's
doing the robot nobody you can get a DJ
twitching a how you looking uh no one
else seems to be doing anything oh god
you're they're [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
Spain is got this [ __ ] Oh Willie ketchup
really cat oh yeah Oh what what the [ __ ]
what happens now oh yeah does this mean
what I think it means yeah I knew it I
don't
oh I knew it all along
you hate my voice much oh I'm so happy
oh that was [ __ ] beautiful
that was Japan World Cup won you can buy
this on Amazon if you want to show it to
your friends it's really funny oh man I
had a blast that was so funny ok leave a
like if you enjoy this video I do have
in my hand here
number two if you want me to do this one
as well please leave a like and let me
know and that's all for me for now thank
you for watching and as always stay out
how this game is wonderful name your
horse
Marcia beautiful oh look it's my [ __ ]